one of the longest-serving members of
president Trump's cabinet is revealing
to CBS News the advice he gave the
President on impeachment Housing and
Urban Development secretary dr. ben
Carson says he spoke with the president
about not giving up calling the
impeachment very immature he also
weighed in on some of the key
testimonies during the impeachment
hearings throughout the impeachment
process we saw and heard from career
civil servants you work with a lot of
career civil servants here do you have
any reason to doubt that Foreign Service
officers who testified and the
impeachment proceedings weren't telling
the truth well I mean they're people do
people have various reasons for doing
things that are not fair of course they
do what we really need to be thinking
about is the whole concept of fairness
in a wide-ranging interview secretary
Carson also explained why he has
concerns about possible reparations for
descendents of slavery when you think
about the conversations that have
happened regarding reparations do you
think that's something worth considering
when you look at the inequity with
African American wealth versus white
Americans what I would say about
reparations is you know show me a
mechanism that works you know I did my
DNA analysis okay I'm 77 percent
sub-saharan African 20% Europeans 3
percent Asian so how do you proportion
that out to everybody you can prove
you're a descendant of a slave though do
you think it's worth of money do you get
what percentage of reparations no one is
ever going to be the world considered
percentage of what black people look
like in the civil rights era they didn't
say well we're not going to discriminate
against you because you might be
partially this or partially that
proportionately you're not going to be
the figure out and where do you stop it
it's unworkable so I would much rather
concentrate on how do we provide the
Opera
these four people to get into a better
house yes and you know one of the
reasons we asked him about that is just
how you look at disproportionately
African Americans are in public housing
he talked about that not necessarily
being a destination and then with the
program that you'll be hearing more
about a story
FYI which is people who foster out of
the foster care system aged out rather
of the foster care system 20% of them
end up homeless immediately so they've
started a program at HUD that will allow
people in those situations to have a
voucher and have subsidized housing for
up to three years but again giving them
something based on the life that they've
had and the statistics so I asked you
know and seeing what we've seen with
African Americans the the the wealth gap
is that something that he saw as
something worth having a conversation
about and as you heard there he just
said it's too complicated I find it
remarkable that he called the
impeachment hearings immature because I
think both Republicans and Democrats
would perhaps use the word consequential
but immature I'm more interested to hear
his thoughts about that to someone yeah
it was nice for him to talk to us
because you know he's someone that
doesn't necessarily give a lot of
interviews yeah but again we'll have
more on the program that HUD is doing in
reference to foster the foster care
system and people who age out the idea
also that when you talk about the foster
care system it's like you're starting
from a step behind in what you have and
we talked about that a lot with
economics as well mm-hmm good stuff
you